in order to get ready for Easter 900
middle school students from Faith
Lutheran volunteered all across our
Valley creating crafts with seniors
others made Easter baskets to give away
to kids in foster care it's all about
volunteering the school's principal says
the school does work to make lasting
connections with the community
when we serve on this day we don't want
it to just be a one-day experience so we
hope to make a connection that's lasting
and maybe we come back maybe We Gather
donations at school and we send them
there's a variety of ways that we stay
connected with these organizations
some of the kids also picked up litter
at Clark County parks